there were reports leaks that there was
a military operation in the offing uh
according to the uh one of the men
themselves who called his father the
building they were in and the east of
junior had been surrounded by the
israeli military and police and
according to his father they decided to
give themselves up to prevent further
civilian casualties they said they'd
been threatened that the building would
be destroyed if they did not come out
the israeli military saying both the two
remaining prisoners and two people who
had been helping them were all arrested
and are now being questioned there was a
statement from the israeli military
saying that there were uh violence
there was violence afterwards with um
locals from the area uh they said
throwing rocks and improvised explosive
devices at police they reported live
fire as well certainly uh we do know
that there have been protests
there was concern that if there was a
major violent end to this this manhunt
that it could end in a very bloody way
and potentially spill over into wider
violence so i think the israelis will be
happy that they managed to to get these
men back without that kind of gunfight
at the end of it
you